how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to the channel just a heads
up I'll be posting on my superhero
central channel today and my cosmic
culture channel today as well
so if you like this content and want
similar content be sure to head over and
subscribe to both channels today we have
some pretty big news about Doctor
Strange and the multiverse of madness we
have some big production news and we
also have some news about a new director
dr. strange in the multiverse of madness
when it was announced at San Diego
comic-con of 2019 said it was going to
be the MCS first horror film the film
was originally supposed to be directed
by scott derrickson who directed the
first Doctor Strange film who has a lot
of experience in the horror genre but
not too long after Kevin Feige came out
and said that it's not going to be a
horror film
it will have some aspects of that genre
but overall it's not going to be a
horror film so we could clearly see that
there was some disagreement going on
about the film and the direction of it
and then not too long after that it was
revealed that scott derrickson had
parted ways with Marvel Studios on
directing the film but he stayed on to
be an executive producer and of course
this freaked everybody out they needed
to find a new director dr. strange too
is one of the most anticipated movies of
phase 4 and nobody wants it delayed well
it looks like we have good news there
were rumors going around for a while
that Sam Raimi the director of the
original spider-man trilogies was in
talks to direct the film well now it
appears that it's official and it looks
like Doctor Strange and the multiverse
of madness may begin a little bit
earlier than we thought it would Sam
Raimi was set to attend Monster Mania
Khan next month however it was revealed
that he will not be attending Monster
Mania in Khan because he has to film
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness now this came from a tweet from
the official Twitter account of Monster
Mania Khan and it said I've just been
informed that Sam Raimi's appearance at
Monster Mania and Khan has been
postponed due to filming Doctor Strange
- we would plan to bring him in for a
future show as soon as possible so
clearly somebody at Monster Mania Khan
was told hey Sam Raimi can't come
because he has to film Doctor Strange in
the multiverse of madness and that's
what this person tweeted out however the
tweet was soon deleted and then a new
tweet went up saying just been informed
that Sam Raimi is forced to postpone his
appearance at Monster Mania Khan due to
filming
we hope to have him at one of our future
shows so they took out the part where it
says he's going to be filming Doctor
Strange too so it looks like they posted
the original tweet got in trouble for it
because Marvel doesn't want anybody to
know that Sam Raimi is on board yet and
then released a new tweet but of course
it's the Internet everybody took a
screenshot of it now this is pretty big
news because this means that Sam Raimi
couldn't attend Monster Mania Khan
because he asked to attend to Doctor
Strange to Monster Mania and Khan is
scheduled between March 13th and the
15th that is less than a month away
which means Doctor Strange and the
multiverse of madness pre-production is
starting extremely early which is great
for us because as soon as pre-production
starts we usually get leaks and then of
course when production starts we get
photos and videos as well and this is
great because there have been so many
reports and rumors for dr. strange in
the multiverse of madness for example
Mikey Sutton has said that the
Illuminati are going to be appearing
making their MCU debut in Doctor Strange
2 and the Illuminati will bring
Professor X Namor and mr. fantastic of
the Fantastic Four and we know that
Patrick Stewart met with Kevin Feige
about reprising the role of Charles
Xavier in the MCU and according to the
Twitter accounts smart Tom it was about
a role in Doctor Strange 2 and really
anything is possible in this movie where
the multiverse exists and Doctor Strange
has access to infinite amounts of
universes and it's even more exciting
when you realize that Sam Raimi the
director of the spider-man films could
bring back Tobey Maguire spider-man for
an appearance that would completely just
blow everybody's mind and it would be a
quick cameo probably wouldn't be for
anything big but everybody would love it
so big news we seemingly have a new
director Sam Raimi for Doctor Strange -
in the multiverse of madness what do you
think about this and who would you like
to see in Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness don't forget to
hit that like button and subscribe and
notifications turned on to enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 and picking a winner at five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
as always thank you all so much for
watching well for